[Music]
hello and welcome I'm Grandmaster Dennis
bch and this is preparing like a pro um
this time we are going to discuss a
topic which is seldom discussed in
general and that is space as a weapon
now mostly this will feature magnus
games and the very first one is Magnus
Carlsen playing Lazaro
brone so
E4 C5 Knight F3 E6 D3 now D3 is not the
most topical move most of the time D4 is
being played at the highest level in
fact famously this was a match up
between Magnus Carlson and
ivanchuk but this time Magnus opts for
D3 which seems to be a bit more
restricted however you may notice that
white tries to keep the structure intact
so what you'll see is that Magnus is
going to go for long-term ideas trying
to gain space and use that space for his
advantage
Knight C6 G3
D5 and of course we ended up in a
classical Kings Indian attack it is of
course the American Champion's
favorite obviously Bobby fiser now Bobby
fiser usually played it with Knight to
D2 Knight
bd2 and then continued on with his
development famous for the Fisher on ER
game which we're not going to delve into
but I'm pretty sure you may have seen
that one
before however in this case Magnus plays
Queen E2 a favorite of
Trin and a move that actually has a
different
idea Queen to is saying my Bishop I mean
magnus's Bishop is going to be very
useful when it's opened up and the
Knight isn't just going to block its
view so Queen E2 is sort of an attempted
Improvement or at least an alternative
of playing this variation without
committing the Knight early Knight
F6 Bishop G2 Bishop E7 castles and B5
now in the other game black is going to
Castle and andite actually attempts that
E5 push
in this game black decides to go
B5 and our big question will be how
should we respond as white so these are
all the important things in chess
whenever your opponent does something
unusual Strays from the normal patterns
that actually gives you a free chance a
free shot at doing something original
yourself so the big question is whether
we should continue the same way or
should we mix it
up note that the decision of going B5
still left Black's King in the center so
it is in some respect different from the
lines with
castling hello good evening
everyone from Colombia
hello Brian hello Patrick and many
others so what would be the first thing
that I would note is this bishop on G2
actually potentially having some targets
all along the
diagonal so you'll have to find a way to
exploit
it so today's lecture so we're going to
go out in a Lim and say
E5 okay that's one way of looking at it
anyone with a different
idea from St Louis welcome
Mike in hello B9
form so often
times it is worth noting what your
opponent is doing in this case this is V
in the long diagonal cver is an
interesting idea however it would run
into captures captures and the E Pawn is
hanging probably night
takes but the direction is right you are
trying to open it up and that's what
Magnus did he actually went for E takes
D5 exactly thank you Alex e takes D5 and
I know we're talking about space but it
does not necessarily mean that you have
have to be dogmatic in
fact
space can be gained in different ways it
doesn't really have to be E5 although
that's the trusted Fisher method so e
takes D5 e takes D5 and D4 so even
though this is not like the traditional
way of gaining space or the way You'
think about it but what is sort of
lacking space this Pawn is not
really taking control of the center so
even though white is wasting a move d4
gains that little bit of space why does
this work well now white actually
targets the B5 Pawn hits the C5 Pawn
concurrently and it means that because
black actually didn't Castle early on
white can take take advantage of those
Von pawns on on the queen
side C4 is played and the next move is
actually very very very nice and
tactical at the same
time of course C4 was more or less
forced because otherwise one of the
pawns would have
fallen and this next move by Magnus is
fairly creative but also extremely
logical noting the fact that the black
king is still in the middle so
technically if white could gain a
momentum or gain the right type of
momentum he could get the
initiative A4 probably I will push my
Pawn in that case it's even more
energetic than A4 but you are looking in
the right
direction
Knight
E5 it is upon sacrifice now if you go
Bishop
G5 I'm just in time to Castle and you
can't really punish
black the interesting part of Knight D5
is that white is willingly giving up a
pawn saying well if you take my Pawn
which Bron did I will have an easier
time targeting that pawn on D5 also it
gains more space and gets the Knight on
a beautiful
Outpost so Knight takes
D4 Queen
D1 eyeing both the D5 pawn and the
Knight on
D4 Queen
B6 Bishop B3 pinning It to Win It Bishop
C5 and let's try find the next move for
white it's fairly logical but hey a good
move is a good move there's no such
thing we may label them in any other way
but a good move will always be a good
move
adust
B before in case of B4 C takes
B3 oh yeah just a little bit of a
disclaimer maybe is
autocorrected so it's going to be
deleted
immediately why because it doesn't quite
exist not in this lesson or in this
lecture synonym
don't work
either but good try good
try Knight C3 indeed Knight C3 is the
move of course you want to develop and
set up a threat that is actually 101
initiative you want to develop your
pieces and you want to set up a threat
immediately so that's why actually mag
's idea of Knight E5 is so strong
because he's immediately setting up
threats that BRZ will have to deal with
if you go Bishop takes D4 the issue is
black captures back and you're actually
losing an important part of your attack
the dark squared
Bishop so Knight C3 Bishop E6 however
even though you played this energetic
move Knight C3 get the Knight to E5 go
Bishop E3 you still got to keep on
rolling black is not so far away from
safety well if black decides to go here
I take here take here and I got immense
pressure on your pieces I mean of course
The Rook is hanging as well so in fact
in that scenario br would be under
pressure and not and be down well he's
not down upon in that case but he
definitely would be worse in a position
where he doesn't even have the extra
Palm so what looks um kind of tricky in
this position is that it seems seems so
safe for
black however there is something loose
in Black's
Camp Knight D5 you capture back if you
take on
D4 your knight is still hanging so
Knight takes B5 doesn't quite
work
but as I said earlier you don't want to
part with your dark squared Bishop
unless success is Within
Reach just look at the direction where
cin is playing usually you want to play
on the side where you're strongest most
of your moves has been
aiming on this side of the board the
Queen
side so it would be just logical if you
follow up in the same
way and Knight D5 that'd be just a bit
too
much
A4 oh that's
not the move but A4
A4 undermining the B5
Pawn so if you just Castle I can take
this and the biggest issue that black is
facing is that this construction with
the Queen Bishop Knight is not as stable
as it looks anytime this Knight will
move I will have this dastardly move of
Knight A4 and even if you go here I can
take and take your
rock
so A4 might not seem that strong but it
does pinpoint how fragile this formation
is for black so black goes B4 A5 Queen
C7 and now why does play quite pretty
move it's not too hard but you know if
it it's still a
looker
but indeed you could try to go like
Queen D2 Rook D1 might always had
compensation but cin is trying to play
on the loose pieces that Bron
has yeah if5 was there well to make sure
the queen will have to move and also so
it has one other hidden agenda behind
it and that
is to get D A4 Square
exactly Knight
A4 hello hello so Knight A4 point being
if you take on E5 I take on C5 and
things look
sketchy like if you go here I take here
this is is still loose and now my
Bishops will start hunting down the
queen and put on immense pressure in the
center of the board so even if you lose
a pawn the pressure will be just too
much to
handle so Knight A4 Bishop
D6 Knight takes
C4 and here takes on C4
Bishop takes D4 but the funny thing is
you might be wondering if Knight F3
could work but if I can take here so as
you can never capture with the pawn The
Rook would be hanging Queen takes
C4 and now white has this beautiful
little move of Knight
C5 the queen is near
trapped over
here and white also has this bishop E2
move and once I pick up this bishop on
C5 it doesn't really
matter that uh like Pawn counts don't
even matter anymore because you can
Castle your king get stuck in the middle
and my Bishops are just going to slice
up your position
completely so therefore black makes the
educated choice of taking
on C4 with the Queen Bishop takes D4
Bishop E7 B3 Queen
C7 okay so credit where credit is due
black is actually defending quite well
um white does have the initiative but
having the initiative often isn't enough
you have to create something more
tangible the initiative is something
that at the end of the day you will have
to
transform to something bigger
and
better and don't forget black is still a
single move away from
safety most of what Caron did so far is
extremely logical
just decided that Black's King is
vulnerable in the center so he may as
well go after
it so he actually went for C4 which is a
great move you're trying to hit the iron
while it's still
hot Rook E1 would give ample time for
black to get the king into safety rook
d8 and now he's going in Bishop takes
Bishop takes Tak C takes
D5 H
look you like white play good for you so
C takes
D5 um the funny thing though that Bishop
takes Bishop takes C takes D5 might
actually
succeeded the hardest part that actually
black had a chance to take the
advantage
Can you spot this move for
brazon no it was played between Caren
and brazon I am just
here explaining what happened and how it
happened detes indeed
Bishop D4 and here is the most
remarkable
move that BRZ had to find and it's not
at all
easy
castles and the funny thing is you're
pinned black is in no rush but slowly
but surely he's going to go Bishop F6
and pick up the piece and black is doing
all
right so what's actually fascinating in
any type of game you look sometimes you
get a golden chance to turn everything
around oh you miss it it'll be gone so
after Bishop takes D takes C4 was one
chance for black to turn it around or at
least keep
balance but decided to take which is
logical though C takes Rook C1 Queen
takes
E5 Knight C5 getting the knight in
Bishop
C8
D6 Bishop C3 now you may notice that
this is not your typical space Advantage
but this D Pawn actually is acting as
something of a black piece repellent all
them pieces are forced back there and
they barely can
move so centralizes over defends the
Knight Bishop G4 H3 Bishop
E2 and this next move is very powerful
by Carlson and it again plays on the
idea of gaining even more
space
now black seems to be doing all right
because he's got the Bishops and that's
a form of
compensation for what's happening and
like mean white does have some amazing
pieces in the
center now magnus's next move is pain to
behold
D7 so in this case you can see just
because of the dwn black
Black's Rooks are completely running out
of any moves to
make and D7 is quite strong because it
gives up The Rook but this Rook on F1
wasn't really that useful in the first
place it was sort of a hindrance anyways
it wouldn't really contribute that much
Bishop takes takes back G6 Rook D1 so so
often times um all these super Grand
Masters they're willing to part with an
exchange if they
feel that they can maximize the
potential of those pieces however even
though white is better in this position
there is one more thing that Magnus will
have to look out for what is that
lurking danger that white will need to
consider
while he's trying to win this chess
game because there is a form of problem
we may face even though Knight B7 may
seem
tempting what could be a potential
problem with Knight B7 and trying to win
the material back
back how would that drop the advantage
or why would it drop the
advantage you don't want to trade Queens
exactly if white starts trading pieces
at the end of the day opposite colored
Bishop ending so it's a draw so white is
banking on the fact that he's got extra
space due to the D7 Pawn also that the
Queens are still on the board which in
fact will help him with the attack so
Rook B8 Bishop F1 that is the reason
Knight B7 is avoided by Magnus because
it would lead to mass trades and
potentially a drw bishop F1 the bishop
is moving to C4 Bishop C4 oh Bishop
F6 okay so one step is done it's all
good however we are not done
yet this next set of
plan is pretty nice it's not too hard to
find
but it will be quite
essential for white to
succeed
H4 well black may just go
H5 now not saying H4 is any bad
however you may want to find a plan
that's a bit more aggressive than
that Queen F3 these are one move threats
yes of course you can try to attack the
bishop that's a good idea however your
queen is doing quite well in the
center does the White Queen belong on
the dark
squares I don't think so honestly I
don't think
so so you often have to wonder what will
be the long-term Target for white and
that will help you and will guide you
towards the right move or towards the
move that might be the
strongest the F7 Pawn exactly the F7
Pawn is a big big Target in this
position but right now it's well guarded
by The Rook on
f8
well can go Rook E1 but the point is to
go Rook
E3 the point is to go after oh the F7
Pawn sorry about
those Mouse is just getting a little bit
hyperactive Rook E3 and the point is you
are going to go after
the F7
pawn and once the F Pawn is gone the
King on h8 is going to be ultra
vak five Rook F3 and this is sort of an
empty move white already controls all
the white squares and light squares so
practically it doesn't really set up any
threats Bishop G7 H4 Knight D4 now the
Knight is coming and
over D4 Knight G5
takes Bishop back but the difference is
once white captures on F7 that's just
way too much to handle especially as
Rook H7 Checkmate is on the
cards and here black resigned of course
if you take I takes and I
promote so this was sort of the case
where you use the dewn to gain the extra
space and that was the way to actually
consolidate the advantage and then turn
it into a decisive
one
so the next game is going to be a bit
more
classical in that style of gaining space
and that game is between Magnus Carlson
and dingler
this the same
opening Queen
E2 Knight
F6 Bishop G2 castles castles and you'll
be surprised to hear what white played
in this position probably you won't
be
remember it is obviously about space as
a happen so of course it's Pawn to
E5 Knight
D7 and um well I've been talking a lot
about nimzovich my previous lectures
were all about nimzovich
and
um here you'll actually get to use that
pawn if you overprotect it you may
actually uh get successful however in
this case now white will get extra
options as he did not commit his Knight
to D2
yet so many other cases whenever you
play
E5
white can't do some particular Maneuvers
that Caron will actually accomplish this
game so if you think about this position
what do you think will be Black's main
idea and that should be a
giveaway of what Carlson should do or
what he actually
did D supposed to be chilling not
anymore no chill from ding
well usually white is the one playing on
the king side and not black not saying
that F6 is necessarily a bad
move although it does create a potential
Target on
E6 yeah B5 black usually wants to play
on the queen side while white is trying
to play on the other side of the
board now as white played Queen E2
instead of Knight Knight to D2 white
gets an extra
option which can sort of disate black
from going with this B5
plan also notice that if we consider the
flank and who has more space in the
flank it's clearly black black has two
Pawns
and we don't have
any so how can we compensate for
that it's a fairly strong move by
Magnus C4 very good the whole point
being why is trying to stop that B5
expansion also if they would trade which
would be a terrible
mistake well at least an
inaccuracy in that
case it would be even on the sides and
in the middle of the board white would
have an extra Pawn so just purely on
looking at the middle of the board you
could tell white is better here of
course it's still a dynamic game be
because each side has has one Pawn in
the center however white should be just
a little bit uh considered better due to
the fact that he's got a pawn in Black's
position
D4 um fairly committal deciding to do
the same thing to White getting one Pawn
inside White's
belly okay so any of you remember the
Fisher uniker
game
anyone remembering the Kings Indian
classic
games chat
anyone because this is not that exact
typical Fisher game however the patterns
are roughly the
same so if you are familiar and that is
why why you should study the
classics they do come on in
handy
here my plays the classical
move Rook E1 over protecting the
pawn on
E5 Rook B8
H4
B5 and now you'll see the difference
between the Knight D2 uh lines in this
case white captures on B5 Rook takes B5
and Knight to A3 when the Knight was
already committed to D2 Knight A3
wouldn't be a possibility you wouldn't
be able to win time on The
Rook Rook
B8 okay so remember chess is a game for
two or more if it's a a team game but
but in this case you'll still have to
wonder what your opponent is planning to
accomplish it's clear that they're going
to play on the queen side however you
may want
to just guess what sort of break ding
will be looking
for
yeah black is going to go for the plan
of Bishop A6 and pawn C4 break
exactly that's the main
idea so black already committed on
playing on the queen side so in this
case is not going for the F6 break
so how can white try to stop this
plan how can white stop black from
accomplishing this C4
break
B3 Knight
C4 or rather Knight C4
immediately because that eliminates any
tricks there is a little bit of a
difference between move orders because
if you go B3 black may even consider
giving up a pawn just so he could open
up some files if you go Knight
C4 it is highly unlikely you can go for
any trick
right B6 and now B3 takes we take with
the B
Pawn so for now white is also pretty
happy as black as well cuz he got the
open
file
but on the other hand this Rook ain't
really attacking anything and there are
really any entry squares for the Rook
for the moment at least Rook
B6 so Rook
B6 and now your knowledge of King's
Indian attack will come in handy because
what you're going to see is textbook
Fisher type of
attack and I hope you'll Channel your
inner Fisher right
now
Knight G5 of
course the main idea but the point isn't
Bishop E4 necessarily but to get your
queen to H5 and put
immediate uh pressure on the H7 Square
the leap indeed H6 and Knight H3 this is
actually the main
point white is provoking this hook and
now there is something that callus en
and go
after Bishop
B7 Queen G4 luring the king and now you
can tell that Black's concept went
completely wrong because if he'd go King
H7 white could could just give a check
and even if G6 I could just do the
cheeky Queen H5 move of course can't
touch this and queen takes H6 is just
winning on the spot that's not something
that you can deal with therefore Black
Goes king h8 queen H5
and it feels like it's almost game
over however to credit ding luren is a
very very resourceful player it already
is pretty bad so it's not going to
change the result of the game but is
probably going to be pressing in
eventually when as you'll see however
this next move just shows how
resourceful the Chinese player can
be like to move and find a careful and
carefully crafted interesting
resource
now if black is just waiting idly Bishop
takes H6 is going to happen and
Checkmate you can't quite stop that idea
however the queen on H five is
actually a little bit undefended and is
a potential
Target so black can have a tactical idea
that could exploit
it and it's quite a nice defensive move
as I said
earlier Queen E8 very good but what if I
just take the
pawn well spotted it is Queen E8 and
it's a typical defensive move but what's
the
point F5 very good F5 and of course you
can take aasan which would be pain all
around the board because have pressure
on your E Pawn you can't just defend the
queen because I'm going to win your
Bishop so technically white is forced to
trade Queens in this case otherwise it's
just a free Bishop for no or little
compensation unfortunately for ding
already Magnus got enough of an
advantage which he will capitalize on
but it still shows that there are some
defensive resources here for black and
if he if he would have played it a
little bit
better then black would be doing okay
the bishop sacrifice looks nice but it
doesn't quite
work so takes Bishop D2 King G7 Knight
F4 Bishop F3 even H5 is an idea but
Magnus is in no rush Rook B1 obviously
once you get the advantage on the
position you want to trade takes takes
Bishop A8
H5 trying to provoke some trades of
course this wouldn't work
though G5 Knight G6 ship d8 Rook B5
going after the pawn also notice that he
made sure his only weakness is well
guarded here G4 Bishop B6 A4 and it may
feel a little premature
but he did resign in this position
mostly because A5 is coming and after
the C5 Pawn Falls that'd be just way too
many pawns and black species are really
really
passive black literally can't move that
is correct Patrick
Dy okay so I showed a couple of magnus
games but I want to show a bit about
what's in the
future well there is one n Abdu satov
very very strong USBC player and don't
be surprised if you're going to see him
challenging for the world title in the
near
future so apart from showing a couple of
these magnus games I do want to show you
a recent game by nir backck versus the
reigning women's world champion juven
June so this will be a different opening
but it will be still about space so E4
E5 Knight C6 all the other games
featured the king's Indian attack this
one is E4
E5 D3 and Bishop
B3
um very topical of recent people like
playing with Knight F6 and Bishop E7
even though Bishop C5 was more popular
in the
past and here Juan Jun plays the very
aggressive move and she's trying to
actually question nb's Bishop on B3 but
remember we actually discussing the
topic of
space the big question how can n Beck
respond to this aggressive move while
also gaining control of the
center
C4 now c4 if you are actually pulling
faces while you're listening to me I
agree with you it feels wrong everyone
teaches you that the bishop shouldn't be
completely blocked in by your own Pawn
however this bishop might have a lease a
new lease of life when it goes to A4 and
put pressure on the C6 Knight
also white is completely restricting
Black's play and stopping her from Ever
Getting that D5 break so it is a very
ugly looking move but it has an idea
behind it
so D6 Bishop E3 controlling that square
on D4 also there is this sneaking
technique and sneaky sneaky idea that
often happens whenever white create this
C4 D3 E4
structure eventually white will hope to
get D4 in not in this game but even if
uh you see some English openings that
Knight C3 D4 becomes an idea and after
the trades white does get the marozi
type of structure where black is sort of
lacking counterplay because D5 moves are
restricted so Bishop E3 Knight D7 Bishop
A4 just as I told you white is trying to
put pressure on those Knights Knight B4
very creative however it does lose a lot
of time so what you might notice is that
jeenine is making a lot of Knight moves
and that doesn't really help her to
actually get this bishop out so Knight
B4 A3 Knight A6 Knight C3 and um as
black is sort of passive in this
position there comes an idea he I mean
he is trying to gain space like either
with D4 or eventual B4 how do you think
janun could have tried to balance that
out and this move might look ugly at
first but it will definitely make sense
nonetheless we're looking for a move for
black that looks ugly however is kind of
useful
C5 and I mean it is just as ugly as C4
was when the bishop was still on B3 how
however it discounts and stops D4
forever and the only thing that white
can hope for is a B4 break but even that
is going to take a while while she could
go for an F5 break later on so C5 could
have been something to consider in this
position however I do understand why she
didn't do it it doesn't look that
appealing it looks kind of ugly cuz it
makes her position look like a Swiss
cheese with all those holes on D5 B5 and
F5 so she went for C6 which it actually
is more of a harmonic move Bishop C2
Knight
C5
B4 Knight
E6 Queen
D2 a lot of these positions are hard to
play so even though
some of the moves might not appeal to
you it's always difficult to maneuver
whenever nothing is clarified yet
because white always has this
D4 idea and black always has to keep
that in mind you never really know when
he's going to go for that and based on
that black has to be able to respond
accordingly
KN F6 and all these moves still make a
lot of sense it's not that she has a
terrible position although NRA is
slightly better Knight A4 now taking
advantage of that move and that's
actually what makes close position so
exciting or
interesting is that anytime your
opponent makes a move it may have a
positive side to it but a drawback too
the drawback of her move Knight to F6 is
now Nob has access to the B6 Square ab
ab
B5 CB CB and the question is how should
we follow up and as far as you could see
the position been quite slow but it's
going to pick up pace soon
enough
one of the things that I think sets nbec
apart from the other players is his
Ambitions ambitious play
actually leads to good
results dropping back your knight ain't
that ambitious Bishop B6 is a bit more
ambitious but nir Beck was even more
ambitious than
that went Knight to B6 now it's not at
all that risky because the Knight will
have a way back to D5 but also notice
this immediately pressures Juan Jun to
give up an open file so apart from
having more space now no back has an
open file to work with Bishop B7 Bishop
B3 and pressing all along this diagonal
D5 Rook A7 very energetic play putting
pressure D takes E4 Knight takes E5
Queen
C7
and it is time for us to
channel our USC energy in this
position so jenin is by the way fighting
really well and the position is
objectively well I wouldn't say even but
definitely
tenable boom now takes F7 in comes the
Knight and of course you got to take
that horsey you can't do this bishop
takes E6 and you lose immediately so
this is an invitation you cannot
refuse now in this
case might play the extremely logical
Queen A2 but Queen
A2 is not the
best the shocking D takes E4 is the best
move here and apparently white is just
slowly going to go Knight D5 Queen E2
and black is defenseless against all
those numerous threats but who would go
DX E4 in a practical game not many so I
don't really blame NB for going Queen
A2 now interestingly enough Queen
A2 was inaccurate and ju venun could
have saved herself here or at least get
a position which is
defendable so let's help her let's see
if we can
find this defensive
idea
and it's more of a cold blooded way of
playing King E8 doesn't really help
much and also doesn't look good to be
honest Knight G4 well that would be just
jackpot for
white it's not easy it's not not easy in
fact black should have played the very
very coldblooded move of Rook d8 so King
E8 well of course the issue is the king
is just cutting off your
Rook believe it or not any time you're
thinking of a bad move that doesn't mean
that can't actually help you guide you
towards the right
answer the fact that yall all wanted to
go King E8 well you could do do it
without actually misplacing your Rook on
f8 and after it takes King
f8 black actually is not far
off from doing
okay but of course Rook d8 King f8 in
that case you have to be very confident
that all is going to work out for
you but you know in
chess
sometimes it'll boil down to nerves so
Queen sees um Queen
A2 come back come back to me Queen C6
Rook takes
B7 Queen takes Bishop takes King E8 D
takes E4 and unfortunately for Juan Jun
she was forced to do what you all
considered the best so it's a shame if
you guys would have suggested Rook
d8 maybe she would have found it it's
all you guys's
fault but
seriously black actually is struggling
now because the king is misplaced and
also these Bishops are sniping all
around the board and also know that
Knight is actually still so strong on B6
Queen takes C4 Knight D5 and I think
that Juan Jun was more looking at if
she's looking if she's losing
immediately but in fact even though
she's not losing immediately her pieces
are so badly
misplaced there's no question that her
position is bad so Bishop d8 H3 even at
the highest level you got to create a Lo
for the king Rook F7 not even
considering capturing that Rook
Knight takes check Queen D6 check of
course if you go here you get back
ranked King E8 Bishop takes D5 Queen E7
and let's find the last
move that nirb played and after that
juanjuan
resigned one more move and everything
collapses
Queen C6 of course and it was a game
over because if you go Queen D7 there's
Bishop takes F7 I take the Rook take the
game if you go here Bishop
C5
and those Infamous Bishops just snipe
away and it is game
over so I really hope you could notice
that with the idea of gaining space you
get more opportunities to gain an
advantage so I hope you could learn a
thing or two how you could use that to
your benefit so thank you so much for
watching and hope you'll come again
thank
you
[Music]
a